we have to look for
an act respected
hello everyone welcome to our twitch
stream I'm Isaac France this is Dennis
this is Dennis boorish and he is our
Grandmaster today today we will be
crushing the people yeah just as usual
standard business just like yesterday
when I crushed all of you
Dennis will also be crushing you so go
ahead and challenge us online and I see
we got a few already
yeah fast time controls like three oh
what time controls are you looking for
today Dennis anything from one to three
or anything from one to three or even
five but that's a rare occasion okay
alright so if you're if you're
challenging to anything probably five
minutes make sure that there's no
increment on that but three oh three two
one oh one one two one crazy things like
that go ahead and challenge us oh I
should I should post that link I should
post the link of how to challenge us
I'll find it and then I'll and then I'll
post it in the chat but even if I tell
us about your favorite Johnny Cash songs
tell about my favorite Johnny Cash songs
the only one I know is ring a fire so I
suppose it's that one isn't the one when
you're just laying wearing black for
people oh there's some sort of like
dressed in black song yeah I don't know
that I don't know what the actual yeah
go ahead and click one of those
challenges let's get a game started oh
that's good
start it alright should I follow them
let's let's follow my dreams your dreams
of d3 my dreams of its it's the best
there's there's the challenge link Thank
You Dani
hello Alberto hello Tariq hello David
curry hello Rafael
hello any problem yeah David curry is he
a basketball player not Steve curry no
David curry he might also be a
basketball player but but I cannot
confirm or deny I was a basketball
player for a little while but on
freshman high school or in my freshman
year in high school the day before the
basketball tryouts I burnt my hands my
dominant hand and
so I went to basketball tryouts without
a dominant hand and I didn't make the
team that's why I wrestled in high
school ah because it's the same season
okay
hello skull agar man someone said hi
there but their name is in white so I'm
gonna highlight it and then I'll be able
to see it - hello mark Brock hmm that's
attack your aggressive those King side
pawns are ya up in their face I really
hope I don't get made it I think you can
do it I believe in you you believe in me
I have a dad that's good I have faith
Queeny 7 Oh be my guest Castle queenside
yeah you saw all your pawns on the Kings
side and said I'm gonna Castle queenside
I'm so scared but exactly but he's
already pushed those bonds so they're
gonna be weak as well
yeah I'm actually actually having lots
of fun all over the boards and that's
what you do you have control of all of
the board yes
although and throw all of the ball all
of your board are belong to us yes I'm
telling you like to assimilate if you
must assimilate blacken you must have
become a part of the Borg
hello Muhammad Magdi I remember you
didn't get a game yesterday so let's
make sure that you don't or that we
don't miss you it again today
hello Nicholas Curatolo I don't mmm dl
dar sham sunny hello hello Omar jabber
that sounds great Alberto come to our
club and challenge us I knew it that
he's going to Castle you knew he's gonna
Castle I think I saw this position in my
dreams
is that fair actually yeah if you if
you've already seen a position in your
dreams are you cheating yeah that's a
question I don't know what fetus is
about that yeah what does feed a feel
about falling asleep of the board and
then dreaming up good chess moves and
then playing them yeah did that come
from your own mind how can we tell
that's true that's a it's a good
spiritual question actually happened
like one of the Hungarian and
international masters came up
an idea in the evening show panning
while sleeping oh really yes yes are
elated and almost crushed is up on them
that's great yeah that's one of the
coolest stories I know hello servic what
timings are you accepting challenges
anything faster than 504 ibly 3 3 or 1
with an amount or no amount of increment
yep trying to sneakily check me my
opponent yeah if you're doing if you're
doing 5 minutes probably no increment
yeah I'm doing all right
by my standards yes oh yeah you
developed your stuff and didn't hang any
of it okay so that's you know steps 1 2
& 3 to playing a game of chess okay I
know it's really one step but it's so
important that you do it three times
mm-hmm let's get ready to rumble oh my
gosh you're about to rumble yes oh gosh
I don't know if he's ready for this
amount of Rumble Oh am i ready for it
that's another question let's play a
prophylactic move I don't know if it's
good is it really your Bishop isn't pin
later yes they don't take oh my god
there it's not a friendly friendly
person I don't understand why you were
afraid of that Bishop h6 what are the
did you don't know you're just I'm not
actually afraid of it much hey good job
Ryan II feel maddali no it's not ours
all right now let's destroy destroy
attack crush crush I think Roger
checkmate plenty of whoa that's okay oh
wow cuz you got all those dag yeah all
those daddy's right-click right-click
yeah so take that square away the knight
takes this one the diagonal is just
occupied yeah you just got all those
diagonals yep everything is mine it's
all actually his are they you've you
have assimilated add row 81 add row 81
you have been assimilated yes tell me in
the chat how it feels to be part of the
Borg let's always try and go from the
top because those are people Channel
first but but if it's too slow you can
like scatter time control okay go like
stop the top-down cup of Blanca century
if you get a game that's not casual and
less than 500 then you might be
challenged yeah if you're gonna do 500
make sure it's rated so we can steal
your rating points yeah that's right now
we always want rated at least of what we
are have have the GM because then you
can take your points I played the 400
too far dude too aggressive and now
you're overextended yeah some old guy
like in the 1800's said that
don't move your pawns you'll get
weaknesses don't move them just leave
them there just only move your Knights
those are the only pieces that can get
out don't think I'm winning here that'd
be a bit you're awful not winning good I
mean but you you are playing white so
you must be winning yeah that reminds me
of boggle your book saying when I'm
white I'm always winning black I'm
winning because I'm below your vote
that's the best but whatever that's a
great quote where did the GM title go
demoted feels bad man um we just don't
have the GM title because we don't have
GM streaming every day we only have the
GM at least on Thursdays maybe we'll get
GM is to pop in more often than that so
they decided to grace us with the LM
title with the lie Chessmaster title
which is mostly just a you're a
contributing member of the streaming
community and you play chess on our site
it's not really a you are this good at
chess title I guess it's more like I
love you title yes I love you it's the
love you masters title you missed it
should be a club to love youngsters club
Grandmaster Galerie says hi Dennis hey
Corey
I'm sorry chest is my love now you're
gonna be at the bottom of the list I'm
that is unfortunate
yeah we didn't say that earlier what is
your name in in Li Ches
yeah but capito says hungry someone
asked what's your native accents native
accent well I'm from Budapest so I don't
think I have a native accent well
everybody everybody must rate must yeah
everybody does um whatever all right
yeah challenge um whatever next break
the rules and go to the bottom of the
list and show them to that person next
okay ha
free stuff I like free stuff is a tree
well it's semi free let's take this guy
and suddenly we're playing the grid felt
I don't know it's just a famous line
that Kasparov and Karpov played all the
time yeah I should study openings ever
maybe try study openings ever yeah
should I just keep doing tactics for
ever do tactics forever I think we can
also write it on your grave yep your
lies are on still doing tank I still
doing tactics tactics
yes Muhammad Magni I remember you from
yesterday I remember you didn't quite
get a game so I'll try make sure you get
one today ech
I think I'll enjoyed this game but I'm
not sure it will continue
hello Square Sun 1 yeah I'm enjoying
these play the people matches as well we
will keep these going for as long as we
can forever and ever and as we do these
more and more I bet eventually we will
do them longer and later thank you
impro drunk improv drunk improv drunk I
think it's I'm prob drunk I'm problem oh
that was like I'm probably drunk I think
that's what it is yeah I think Johnny
Cash so Lula Prague yes alright um
whatever we're some whatever you do him
whatever and then and then and then
start following the rules again okay
there's a lot of casual challenges and
on that on that list try and make them
rated and if you make a move that would
be also helpful I Navin I remember you
no you should not study anything
oh let's honor our friends online I mean
John John who's John John Bartholomew oh
yeah oh buckling is gonna be in haha I
recognize spec this move I recognized a
chess open and go me oh my god mm-hmm he
knows this he knows this knows it better
than me it's scary to play a GM on an
1800 account though it is it's risky
business yeah
am I the only one who likes Star Trek
and Isaac or does the Chad also like
Star Trek Star Trek's pretty fun
is anybody here like Star Trek anybody
else here
fans of getting assimilated yep there's
there's Star Trek currently happening
yeah I just remember watching the next
generation a millimeter I only remember
that but it's about movies asks for a
tip for beginners please go to chest
tempo calm and do a thousand tactics and
then you'll be better than you were it
works it works that's all I've ever done
and I got it you know thirteen fifty or
something doing that so I'm trying to
make weird moves because that's what
she's supposed to do in the Scandinavian
and if you don't lose you're probably
going to win usually when you don't lose
you in usually but I think that's the
logic of the Scandinavian you have to
survive otherwise you would just lose
that's how
and I think I'm surviving Patrick says
Shatner or bust
really the only the only Star Trek is
the Shatner Star Trek what was the name
of that one was just just Star Trek
right yeah Captain Kirk I didn't have a
second title to it so data or the name
[Music]
yeah data or 709 I don't know who that
is the second one is so data data yeah
it was great well one of my favorite
episodes was when data got like captured
and locked in a room and that guy wanted
to play chess with him keep him as a
museum and there was a chess game in
there sword in there cool in the room
actually I have this extra guy and shall
go use Navon you will certainly get to
play today do you have a challenge on us
make sure it's rated because we're gonna
we're gonna skip all the Unrated ones so
if you make it rated you probably going
to be closer to the top of the list and
I hope I could make like five moves in a
row because then I would be be leavening
but obviously this is fine I've been
struggling with approximately 1600 élow
for quite some time now any tips to get
better tactics tactics tactics are
really the answer until you're about
like 2,300 yeah
opening prep can help but it can only
get you so far if you can't calculate
the endgame
oh I have beitia bad you do a Fisher
para PL so don't have a jeep on that
your kings on that file yeah I'm a
little scared no not really
there might be an amount of compensation
for the bishop pair probably that's I
want to get good at chess but don't want
to memorize lines I feel like it takes
away so don't memorize just do tactics
just play good don't
don't necessarily learn focus on what
the craziest our best opening theory is
just play the moves that you get
comfortable with and get positions that
you are comfortable with and then do a
million tactics yeah just be the cool
guy yep there was somebody who just like
last year got to IM or something without
ever studying openings wow he said I
never studied openings just a tactics
and he hit I am yeah you just need to be
able to calculate and see the board
Amelia moves ed yeah million moves
that's not much just a million just a
million it's like not that far yeah is
he gonna take your pawn yeah why do you
take my stuff I don't want to give it to
you whoa I hope I didn't blow under you
never know oh thank you for phone hey
you got a pawn back yes
no it's even we're even-steven
I think I'm whatever's gonna crush you
there Cormac bear Cormac Oh bear is well
on his way to a million he guesses well
good job get there and then you'll be
the best chess player in the world
how many tactics do you think you've
done in your lifetime 10,000 and plus
and Counting ten thousand plus and
Counting mm-hmm maybe that's not even
that much I
I bet it's it's gotta be higher than
that I think so I mean I feel like I've
done a thousand two thousand okay but I
live when you only had heavy books from
them and not computers right you just do
it over and over and over and just click
all the buttons yep yeah they give you
for free
surely it's easier to calculate tactics
if you play a consistent opening
I assume that is correct at least for
the early game would you would you agree
with that which one that it's easier to
calculate tactics if you play consistent
opening that you're comfortable with
yeah yeah absolutely you start to
recognize what tactics are prevalent in
those situations and which ones you can
come up with often yeah you can come in
you're fine we are we are live but like
you can come in it's fine I'm in you
must join us that night on a1 is not the
most aggressive piece I've seen in my
life
no that is a passive piece and oh oh my
that's also Star Trek quote oh yeah
that's uh yes yes I taketh this bond how
do you find updated theory on openings
usually when I play tournaments I feel
like I'm out prepped every time I don't
know well search for opening sites I
don't work I can't you just take that
guy what happened well I up right no way
did you lose a miner at the end there's
no I didn't I mean I took his bishop so
everything's wrong that's Bush bow I
also like to improve but really I think
you should focus on what you find to be
fun yeah absolutely the most important
thing to getting better is to keep
studying whatever you can enjoy studying
if you don't enjoy studying don't study
they would study just play yeah if you
enjoy studying tactics like me that's
pretty much the only thing I like to do
oh and I'm slowly getting better just
doing that if you like opening theory a
lot which I don't know what kind of
masochist does then just keep studying
opening theories and
maybe you'll get winning advantages but
you need to be good enough of tactics to
convert those winning advantages also if
you like westerns you should watch a lot
of western movies then yeah if you like
western movies watch western movies it's
actually very good for your chest you
learn survival skills there if you like
bling buck house oh thank you for
playing me um whatever um whatever it
was a pleasure it was a great great
pleasure all right let's see who wants
to challenge us is alright find some
just start from the top and click the
glute we want to make sure that
everybody who challenged us get a game
he's a casual Mohammad Maggie I also
seem to be pretty inconsistent one game
I blender a piece the other upbeat in
1900 that isn't that crazy I think
people's people's ratings are more about
a consistency than a strength yeah it's
more about there's plenty of 1300s who
could beat the occasional 1900 but they
just can't do it on a regular basis and
that's why they're rating is 1300
talking about consistency have you seen
this ten years before and now challenges
on the internet no what is that what's
exciting is that on social media
hello guy inbox and on other sites as
well you could see how the feeder
rankings changed and then you see a
certain Peter swindler on 20 hmm then
you see the next one and you see a
certain Peter Switzer on 20 and that's
consistency oh he's just been 20 forever
yeah he's been 20 forever mm-hmm he's
very consistently that good yeah I mean
that's a sign of being very very good if
you're up there and you score oh maybe I
win something maybe this is my lucky day
yes thank you for the Queen that's a
good one
that'll be a game ender I think this
will
painful Richard pointer suggested puzzle
rush I was puzzle rush in terms of
getting better at chess yeah I think
puzzle rush is probably pretty good but
Richard I think you need to be able to
get more than 25 like maybe 26 or so 26
is pretty good 25 mm not so much Richard
thank you mr. mapps thank you for the
game hey play with me says Subic as long
as you're on the list and we're gonna be
going in chronological order we're gonna
click all of the rated from the top down
I found someone oh yeah oh yeah you did
find him you did find Subic yeah let's
honor mr. Finn's yet again mr. Finn's
yeah Bartholomew has also caused mr.
Finn's arm Richard pointer got 30
yesterday and he has proof
yes proof he says he has proof I bet he
took a picture of it I bet did you frame
it did you send it to mommy did you tell
her all about it let's see puzzle rush
means you spend half the time doing and
redoing less than 1500 level puzzles
yeah but a lot of people need that and
it's not bad for anybody to do it's
healthy they say like you should do like
two puzzle brushes a day and then you
say healthy forever
yeah two puzzle Rush's a day keeps the
doctor away that's what I've heard
framed in gold
Richard pointer framed it it's in gold
it's above his bed it's actually on the
ceiling when he wakes up in the morning
as motivation I you have all your scores
on the ceiling like 16 15 35 I mean I
that's the way I will do it how did this
get blocked I don't know
do people still watch westerns I don't
imagine so really nobody does watches
westerns
I feel old does does Django Unchained
count as a Western yeah kinda kinda does
Western just mean like there's Cowboys
in it it's kinda general what about the
the one that came after that like seven
or the seven seven Magnificent Seven
that's definitely a Western so is
Charles Bronson the best western actor
or is it clintus fine I don't know who
that is no he did actually charge
Bronson did once upon a time and what
you got what you guys like that though
maybe somebody in chat knows okay
Charles Bronson in a western movie okay
sacrifice let's make this game Lively
Chuck Norris it's another arles Bronson
or Chuck Norris well it was this was
this guy in Pulp Fiction was he the wolf
in Pulp Fiction yes he was I just saw
his he looks like that dude
can the Chet help us with this oh yeah
he's very important for you she was not
still acting when that movie was made he
was in the Indian runner is that I don't
know if has an Indian name in it maybe
that's a Western yeah said he was often
played by he often played cops and stuff
all right now you now Chad knows all
about Charles Bronson also watch Once
Upon a Time in the West it's pretty good
no no no can't make me I won't
you must assimilate you must become part
of the Borg yes
so we have penguins and John you should
challenge them bring it on I don't hurt
penguins you don't hurt penguins say
penguins penguins pretty good does he
just leave his computer on he does play
a lot of Blitz Jesse bullet chess I
usually use my computer as a pillow we
are the beard surrender your face and
prepared to be bearded resistance is
futile I love it guy in box yeah I have
to grow my beard back yeah you had a
beard for a little while remember yeah
um what's wrong or do you like
SuperDuper checkmated if you take that
ya know it's just a sneaky move
yeah I used to in college I would like
but I would carry my pens in between
classes my beard I think that's not a
unique idea I see I've seen lots of
people do it all right
I'm not special but it is fact it could
be special but I set a timer to 3
minutes plus 2 second increment is that
a problem no that is fine nothing is a
problem I don't think you seem to be
apiece for a pond after this would you
like to do hands and brain but me being
you being the hand and yeah we could do
some hand a brain let's do a gamer - a
hand in brain we're gonna crush whoever
we play whoa tricky I'll take this guy
though that is no good for them yeah
I'll give you a goodbye check bye
goodbye you will be missed
say hello to my little friend my little
friend the Queen the Queen all right
servic challenges to five plus one is
that fine that is too slow yes maybe if
you did four plus one he'd accept it but
may not all right from the top let's do
it okay and handled right hand and brain
all right I'll be the brain I'm big big
brain Isaac on the case Isaac
pawn it doesn't matter Paul matter okay
three two has been Simon's preferred
time control that is a fact Ben Simon
also loves to do best of tools Bond who
went that way
never go that way let's do a night
working on my night moves
let's do night woo very professional
very professional very professional
always trade let's do a night I'm going
with a bishop
novelty Isaac's novelty my novels yeah
which one bishop moving here no King why
is that a novelty because people don't
play it people just don't play that yeah
good to know
so car yeah can remember we did at first
hmm pawn yeah yeah and we're on the same
page on that one
Dennis you're sounding like Vichy
apparently really night
I'm sure Bischoff would disagree hmm he
never agrees with me
fun is that the pond that was the move
out so far I think you've played every
move that I want to do so far we're dude
yeah what's cuz were part of the Borg
together bishop so maybe mind-reading
does work maybe
night
Don
pun on
hmm all right all right
rook what is it too cowardly no I mean
if he would not still still there's
still something that in case
Oh night Oh hey smell blood hey smell I
smell blood
yes I'm not that ocula hmm Dennis what
is your opinion on the younger talent
the amount of work that they put in
towards their chests success let's go
with Queen what do I think about young
talents just like do you think that
young people put a lot more work into
becoming successful I get I guess or do
they have to do less work because of the
night because of the resources they have
these days or what do you think yeah I
mean they do have huge advantages
compared to us mm-hmm because they can
only rely on computers which is not good
Bishop Bishop yeah yeah oh my god oh
sorry I think you only played one move
that I didn't expect the gym have any
book recommendations Oh hmm definitely
the great predecessors is a great book
but I would read some Bronstein books
cuz he's hilarious and such a great
player too nice
hmm well one of those bishops is gonna
move so Bishop Bishop all right let's
pull the bishop here okay
I'm just trying to annoyed the guy Oh mm
oh gosh bishop again well we got to move
a bishop again I think I hate moving
bishops
I hate it Queen okay you can move that
it's a waste of a tempo probably yeah I
just wanted to say something other than
Bishop yeah cool rook oh no oh no oh
we're SuperDuper in trouble oh gosh it's
not that bad actually good were
threatening I advise taking I'm going
with King okay oh my god are you getting
checked we're gonna check and/or wrecked
hopefully just checked well I don't know
if they've check us isn't that good for
us well nope cuz you play King e7 and
then we're attacking his Queen and we
have rook checks cuz he has to do with
this Queen first okay yeah check us
check King h8 is alright how tragic um
tragic
I don't know Bishop I found a move
finally so good you're so good at this
game dude uh this doesn't look the
greatest that's still fine alright let's
just see what you do with no dad then
I'm gonna rock
and I really wish I hadn't allowed
cleaning takes a takes is kind of
painful but pretty painful to deal with
let's fight
things are getting spicy getting hot in
here these are things are getting a
little precarious you know I advise king
I'm going with King okay I bet we go
King again maybe we maybe he forces a
draw here no nothing so you're not
forcing a drawing you don't think so no
what is this King okay all right maybe
he is king king again well what else can
I do
that somebody found a draw took it I
shall be assimilated for this good job
sent home good job
well well done finding that draw yeah
all right I think you probably should
have kept playing though cuz yeah I'm
the one telling him to make moves so
yeah you didn't really draw a GM you
drew meat all right let's see
Skol night all right so don't lay
against call Island Skull Island that's
actually butts Indiana Jones no oh I was
thinking it was the big gorilla King
Kong
oh yeah yeah King Kong alright that too
I think there wasn't when do you play
Navin uh I don't know did you see your
name on the list how many people do we
have to go through to get to you and
amount one two three for you for you are
four games away is Dennis an alternate
spelling of the name Dennis yes yeah
it's just a not American spelling of it
yes
Dennis reminds me of Tobey Maguire from
pawn sacrifice thank you we take that we
take Fisher compliments as a compliments
or fissure comparisons with commitments
Bishop Bishop alright you only move one
of them
what I know I just wanted cowardly no
it's already a novelty actually it's not
but were you among the kids who got
lectured by been Feingold
no no the time I met by and fungal that
was a man
we both had beards already yeah I had a
beard before I knew been so no Fisher
was spider-man confirmed
agreed so what music do you listen to
Isaac when you play chess when I play
chess um night I listen to mostly I mean
anything without words it needs to not
have words okay I can't I can't do
lyrics because I'd like to listen to
lyrics to night tool well screaming
counts as lyrics okay screaming lyrics
yeah I just listened to lots of the
instrumental stuff whoa Oh are we
getting them why not
we're going we going after and pawn yeah
don't get up rage against the bishop
you're gonna get got do you know go
Harry
I agree yeah Harry's gonna win us the
game no I never know what to do with
Harry once he's on h5 like sometimes you
want to take sometimes you don't
sometimes you want to just keep the
pressure there and you want to get Gary
involved is it Gary is that that is that
gee I don't know Gary G Gary G yeah Gary
G yeah I mean that's even my Twitter
handle no really got master G for ya
nice but I think that's a cool name for
it Gary did I take the chest broad
approach and listen to dance music yeah
that's that's very possible like EDM
type of stuff that's uh that's good
stuff night night har
yeah good the Meyers way our I mean
there was an R file
well our is closest to this night you
took I'm going with Queen all goodness
I'm going with Queen again
so we're on the attack so that's always
good it's always good that's what you
want
Dress Watch shows the best music really
yeah they they play really good music
while they play sometimes I have their
stream on just for the music and I'm
doing other things not watching their
chest très près are great Airy Barry
Cedric Derrick Eric Freddie Gary and
Harry mm-hmm all right I support us
Freddie of reference to Freddie Mercury
yes absolutely the best vocalists of all
time
yes even her ass my lord oh we've been
harassed I guess we gotta work on our
night moves huh okay or a night shift
yeah it's it's our night shift where
we're working the night shift all right
well you don't want to move them yes
okay
oh goodness all right all right we're in
it whereupon queen yeah let's go
things are getting spicy here this is a
spicy meatball night okay get
nightclothes 'red get the knight closer
King I'm gonna trick medal okay good job
yeah vicious vicious we were relentless
we did not we did not let up good job
all right who's next
looks like it's a list probably seven
probably seven is is Broly or Brawley is
that really is that a video game
character they got the fight is that
like is that the the second boss of the
Final Four oh come on sad was ah or it's
just a name from a different country
yeah Oh Rowley from Dragon Ball Z that's
what it is that's what I was thinking of
what should we do here I'm going with
pawn
it's pong okay pong one ha I guess the
second time yes that's the one I like to
play at pawn hey now we still have
center pawns bishop ha oh damn so
aggressive so aggressive erm I recognize
that name from Dragon Ball Z but I can't
put a face to it which what saga was he
from who was he
huge thank houston we have oh yeah he's
from a movie yeah let's go with Queen
Queen oh okay
well I don't wanna lose that pony yeah
was there a fever double attacked so
that was the issue oh oh it's better to
lose the b-pawn than the yeah the deep
on yeah yeah yep I don't do big we're
going to play like a raging bull so it
doesn't matter pawns don't matter to us
Queen coin I mostly said Queen because I
assumed you didn't want the trade yeah I
assumed you wanted Queen still on board
cuz how long how else can you play like
a raging bull that's true that's true he
was from one of the movies yes I
remember watching that Bishop it was
like a big tree or something there was
some tree he was trying to make wasn't
it uh night
all right
hmm
Oh oh goodness Oh that's probably why
you oh my goodness
pawn move to a square that I can attack
you with a piece please please move to I
don't know B III go Queen b3 please so I
can play Knight something d4 thing yeah
there's less people in chat saying
please play against me yeah there's lots
of people that we want to play against
but we got to keep going down the list
from the top because that's probably the
most fair way to get everybody a game oh
gosh this is so ugly
let's go pong again yeah let's pawn it
it doesn't sound right
defeating a sandwich only makes it
tastier um oh gosh oh goodness me listen
to your heart listen to your heart oh
gosh this is all bad everything is bad
this is so painful he can't survive
somehow we can survive somehow I don't
know if we can survive this this looks
bad
me neither but let's try this looks
really bad the kraang really helps the
crying doesn't help let's go with Queen
Adrienne you're at the top yes you you
are but you challenge us to a casual
game and Denis wants to play rated games
but I'll try making a special exception
to the rule of being on top if you
quickly create us a rated game or a
sandwich I do not envy the task of being
brain for a GM no it's a kind of
stressful actually a little bit hmm
what's going on here
it's not bad it's not it's not bad weird
we're not totally doomed yet no no mmm
Doom is our away just an hour away night
night night night night like that my
hands are shaking
why not Queen a5 check because his queen
is there because his queen will take it
yeah Queen takes b5 is not an obvious
move oh it was pretty obvious yeah
that's what I was that was a pretty that
was a move that should have been played
by me we're only down to pawns and a
knight though we got this think like a
grandmaster I wish I could if I could
think like one I might be one that's
what I'm trying to channel my thoughts
let's bring this King to safety what's
king Knopf
no no okay no no oh I want to play a
bishop on move and then upon moving a
bishop move and okay okay so Bishop what
Bishop the one that can use it
ah no one can legally move that is true
all right Thank You Adrian I'll try to
make sure you could play next
just think about what Dennis would do
yeah WW dee dee what would Dennis do
sometimes when I'm playing games of
chess I think about the moves that I
would instantly make and I go I know
that that's a common low-rated type of
move to make and I just try and play
anything else that might might also have
some validity and it's a new way of
thinking never heard of that
now summers go that is a 1500 level move
mm-hmm find a better one yeah Sheila
don't flack pawn we got this in the bag
move there's our move let's go with
Bishop attack attack always attack crush
destroy assimilate dish up I got you I
got you so good
do we have any spicy meatballs here I
don't know well not chicken soup is
sometimes Bischoff
maybe we just try and win faster than
him we just aren't play faster than him
movie went on time fish up Oh God Bishop
Bishop where Bishop the blood the black
one
okay you're losing time
oh that's true okay King all right I
mean remove Queen okay
remove oh gosh Bishop Bishop earth we
know cleanup Queen okay I thought he
would take it bishop how tragic
oh how tragic tragedy a great game
Brawley you defeated us it's too bad you
couldn't defeat Kakarot there's some
there's been some sort of adrian name
though like we'd a lot of them like way
to the bottom Adrian like Brody like
Broly yes we the with the scroll yeah
we've never got to go like all the way
to bottom yeah that a dream at the
bottom yeah play that guy why is it five
plus so well we said five oh it was fine
okay okay all right
pawn
more puns more bonds okay
nice I like it I like it I support it
fun
um yeah yes yes so this is a Queens
gambit accepted with three Tempe down
nice yeah actually it is Wow Queen
maybe we kind of got our pond back yeah
Queen yeah that was something Mohammed
we did did great now or we did great in
that game we fought hard
let's go with Queen again there was
something special to say say the least
still theory night how often is a Dennis
play to become a GM I'd probably a lot
probably most of his life eight nine
years yeah just play like a GM loll yeah
that is why don't we don't really die
for all do that just do that it's so
easy it's like one sentence Queen
this is like an opening that I kind of
play but down a million tempo okay play
only two minutes games yeah we'll try
and play yeah as fast as we can play
yeah I guess maybe five 500 was a little
slow but yeah well go back to two
minutes or three minutes or two minutes
let's go with the show okay Victor just
subscribed with twitch twitch Prime
thank you very much Victor q Victor we
are we are happy to have you as a twist
subscriber pretty soon we're gonna be
trying to figure out how to actually get
the things to appear on the screen King
now we're trying to get OBS working with
our TriCaster so soon we'll actually
able to see your names pop up when you
subscribe and you'll be able to give us
messages when you donate and stuff too
so now we actually transpose into a
green felt well we're in the groove oh
yeah bishop
I'm sorry servic I thought five-o would
be okay but Denis burrows is so strict
and he wants faster yeah I'm a strict
person if there's anything I know about
you Dennis it's that you're super strict
yeah transpose to trick your opponent
yes we started down a million tempo yeah
and now we're not down a million tempo
um work on our night moves
Night Moves work in on our night moves
um we push up on I'm gonna take a night
I want that book zeger spend feingold as
far as I know oh okay Queen pal WAPA pal
it's a Catalina Wine Mixer
actually you know this is a really nice
green fold for us yeah I think it's
actually really good for us is it harder
to become a GM they'd learn to speak
Hungarian
clean clean that's actually an
interesting question
yeah it's harder to learn a language or
become a GM probably learning the
language is much easier and probably
it's just like a little bit less
in-depth language all a more exactly it
takes years to become a GM mm-hmm I
guess we got to go Queen again huh okay
yeah it's probably a lot there's a lot
more people that can learn languages
then can become Grand Master's probably
yeah I kind of wanted to go Queen Bee
seven so I stole a lot of pressure on
that night and I can push a pond at one
point but night but night okay well
Caleb Denby be a regular on st. Louis
streams very likely because he is a good
chess player and doesn't have a ton of
responsibilities at the Chess Club so I
think we're gonna try and give him some
streaming responsibilities oh goodness
oh goodness me Queen
let's run run away we want to keep our
queen we like our queen
all hail the Queen
Oh hail the Queen can you recommend us a
chess book no wait again
the Zurich book by Bronstein or anything
that's Bronstein anything Bronstein and
the Zurich book by Bronstein well so
actually the one that's even better is
Sorcerer's Apprentice yeah you can you
can you can choose a language you
already have roots in like Italians for
Spanish speakers etc yeah I mean while
it's hard to have roots and chest
language we got to go clean again just
keep moving your queen every time you
tax it okay yes I shall do sir don't
worry George tier I yeah three plus two
is short enough you'll definitely get
you know definitely get picked yeah
we're gonna stay on the list let's go
with pawn yeah I've been wanting to do
that for so long
but our queen just kept getting attacked
finally we winning a piece because we're
overloading this guy yeah there's
there's so many things then that Bishop
can't stay on that diagonal defending
the knight and there's only one defender
after this Bishop moves then we take
with our Bishop yeah and then you take
to the night and you take with the Queen
yeah I've been wanting to do that for so
long doesn't lay do they know how to
play chess with Lady gaga know how to
play chess does anybody know if you
nobody ever seen Lady gaga no chess we
have a picture of her playing chess show
us let's go with Bishop I don't think
you think so I know that sting plays
chess Queen yeah I knew I didn't know
that one exiting the place is band mates
all right yes cool before every concert
that's what everyone they don't enjoy it
you see crush them yes
Bishop are
Oh getcha we're coming at you dude we
are coming to get you
the Queen has arrived the Queen has
arrived
there's nothing defending that bishop
okay I love the but in our rook is not
hanging cool yeah take that bishop
that's kids goodbye to that bishop
bye-bye bishop now we're up to pieces
yeah your Queens attack you should move
it move it I like to move it move it I
like to move it
Reserve the wu-tang clan is the
strongest chess playing magician I know
of yeah I know that he plays a lot I
remember seeing an interview with him
talking about playing chess
all right Knights not like hanging let's
play a rook move let's move a rook to an
open file they've been behind pawns all
game feel bad for him oh guy in box
likes to pre move it move it rook move
it move it there are no Queen made and
then pacifically rook okay
good game Adrian thanks for playing us
thanks for being here yeah all right now
continue from the top rated 3 2 is
probably the slowest will go okay
there's one guy with a 3/3 which was
kind of weird but maybe we'll accept
that one as well
amateurs mind and reassess your chest by
soman yeah I've heard both those books
those both though both of those books
are pretty good but one my brother
always recommends is mastering chess
strategy
he claims that book took him from 1300
to 1500 or 1800 was my back Oh
okay I'll take over there yeah you you
just crush them you just crush them I'm
so worn out man that's all the chest I
can do in one day oh I wasn't even
moving the pieces so tired whoa
see lots of brain power is needed yeah
just don't read how to beat the kid in
public you'll get some funny looks
actually I saw that picture someone
pretty
de Voort ski is a mountain I have yet to
climb I hear about 13 different opinions
on what rating you should be to try it
though is there really do you really
have to be any rating in order to read a
book like there'll be pieces you can't
get out of it won't be inefficient to
read some books before you're a rating
but you're not like there's no way they
if you're not good enough for a book
that it's bad for you to read so I
played this g4 move in honor of myself
because of GM g4 yeah and also because
report plays these kind of moves and
mmm-hmm that's kind of cool
what's your name on Lee chess Mohammed
yeah you were here Rana the beginning so
you should be towards the top of the
list but I don't I am and I don't know
how I don't know how you're not
how much would you have to be paid to
reach 2,600 feet a in a period of two
years be paid like what do you mean how
like I don't understand who would pay
you to reach that I don't I don't I
don't understand your question Mike
who wouldn't pay you it's V zero genius
okay let's make sure we played the zero
genius at some point today because he
was here yesterday wanted a game and
night and I let him down any
recommendations on a solid response to
one e4 well that's a pretty vague topic
and I believe people have been searching
for that since the beginning of chess
8/5 is decent but c5 is the real move
yeah so if I was probably the better
move
I play e5 every time because I can
remember it I just play really boring
stuff and then hope my opponent messes
up that's that's all of my chess playing
knowledge
the latvia gambit is funds as Victor it
is you will definitely get to play today
Navon you you were just a few away I
believe I remember seeing your name see
your name see your name that yeah
see your name see your name I like it is
that a Destiny's Child
actually that's a are now we had to say
my name I thought I thought you're doing
a riff on that
yeah actually night night yeah I knew
that one
how why didn't why did what leave the
auto moderator didn't want to allow bit
c5 as sharp maybe because it looks kind
of like the B word I don't know Dennis
do you think you could draw Mike comer
if he gave you Brooke odds I have to
talk try really hard
good try Navon that almost worked on me
yesterday but you mistyped it and now
I'm prepared for it that's looking
pretty scary for our opponent here yep I
think I'd rather be you are you going to
slaughterhouse him five times
hopefully Soylent Green is people I used
to always listen to Destiny's Child when
I play chess it made me feel like I
wasn't losing and I didn't need no man
mm-hmm
also I have a survivor as excellent for
motivating a comeback it was great it's
a good motivational tunes
I dare you to play the Borg defense next
game do you know the Borg defense I
actually tried to play the Borg defense
is that an actual thing that was he it
wasn't sarcasm I was first I thought
that was sarcasm
where is Mike is he playing he plays
tomorrow we have GM on Thursday and Mike
on Friday and then various players on
Tuesday and Wednesday probably Caleb me
Jonathan Perry who probably all be
playing to my little friend your little
friend is in it to win it
yes yes max is Mike placed tomorrow
and those are the streams that go on
forever because the game Mike likes to
play chess forever
pretty much just plays chess until the
FAQ starts let's do let's do the Borg
you have to be black to play the Borg
who the defense yeah all right both Borg
show me the Borg I must assimilate well
first you have to create a box because
bugs live in a box for seven boxes all
right and cubes actually cubes cubes
cubes well we're kind of on a 2d board
so it'll be hard for us to make a cube
but we can do our best
via building that cube right no cube
being built is Denys good at racing
kings mmm I'm not quite sure what that
is you win if you can get your King to
one of the four center squares oh is it
just the four center squares there's the
fourth Frank general racing Kings for
Center squares all right you can't just
like Robert oh okay
look at that Lou that box you got you
have to with another cube finally some
real talent being streamed here yeah
exactly tomorrow Mike comer is he coming
with the Mike mobile the Mike will be
all the big all blue Ford truck yep I
assume all right I mean if he's owned if
he's like still at home afraid of the so
now even though it's snow from melting
four days okay so we build a double
double Borg defense now I'm planning a
trip to st. Louis in the fall what is
the best time to be at the club
probably sick filled cup is what you're
looking for in August yes well yeah
August is August is a great time to be
here because of the sink filled cup and
then I know a month or so after that
maybe the champion showdown is usually
after the same field Cup in the year
right but yeah definitely August is the
month I would recommend chess player I
don't think the dates have been
officially set or anything for that but
uh yeah it's always in August you know
it's tough to plays the double Borg the
four centre squares is king of the hill
racing Kings is the other side of the
board right is there a Christopher
Christopher you are a Christa perb yeah
recent Kings you have to reach the
eighth rank checking isn't allowed is it
just like checks aren't things like and
you can't take the king or there's like
it's an illegal move to check the king
recent King sounds awful recent Kings is
largely considered the worst variant
according to the that's one guy's
opinion at least I've never played it
what's your favorite chess variant a
buck house
well cows [ __ ] house is always fun what
about like solar put solar player ones
you can play online of them bug house
variants I'm what was it what was that
mystery AV guy in the Box crazy house
Danny is the crazy same thing it's like
one player on one buck house okay yeah
an illegal move to check yeah and racing
kings you can't even check that's pretty
crazy you know the ones that probably
are widely regarded as the best probably
bug house crazy house in 960 was
probably three minutes no nine six about
the hoard hoard is probably my favorite
hordes probably my favorite I love Ford
for too hard for the hoard
yeah I also much rather be the pawns I I
like having a just a massive amount of
I mean someday you'd have to try to
capture Azeroth anyways how you
Americans say my name Victor Gaucho
Gaucho Gaucho well I'm probably not
pronouncing that you enough sorry more
of a gaucho Jojo no I mean a little bit
but it's not that accentuated
Besame Besame Mucho so what's bug house
bug house is a two-on-two type of chess
where you and your partner are playing
opposite colors and whenever so I'm
playing white he'd be playing black I'm
playing somebody who's playing black if
I take a black piece I give it to my
partner and then he can place that on
the board as it in substitute of moving
one of his pieces already on the board
buck houses everything chess should be
I've heard that before
okay so I think as simulation is in
progress
this dude is becoming part of the Borg
yes the Picard I don't
I think it's Justin who's the captain
who's the Meuse data whose data I think
it's like just an unknown starship okay
I hope he blocks with this Queen and
then you take a bishop also defending
your bishop great move I know
wonderful wonderful concept so it's
crazy house on drugs yeah yes sure
that's like it's making you see double I
wish
so confusing to see this hand did you
say night a 3/8 well the night g3 how
crazy is that
yeah I mean I was thinking about that
one but it's just no no there's nothing
to do afterward it's not Borg enough if
you like still had a dark square bishop
on like that see diagonal or you know a
7 to g1 diagonal so my Borg plan is is
to build another cube here in the center
okay not yet until the cube don't get
assimilated dude you're 13 seconds away
from assimilation oh that's be careful
hey that Queen is wait you're frozen no
clock is running
what that's tragic reconnecting or
anything and I think oh my god yeah
we've been assimilated we were
assimilated the Borg got into your
computer yeah and assimilated you you
know how tragic Oh No rest in peace
Hadid smoke Kraft if you're frozen
you've got to let it go man you gotta
let it go all right hey I remember this
guy's name Tarek go go yeah light chest
doesn't have bughouse but does those
chest Khan have [ __ ] house I think it
does can you queue up as a group of two
I wonder yeah yeah cool yeah I would
yeah cuz you want to be able to talk to
your opponent right and I don't want to
like be getting on discord with random
people on chess calm that sounds sketchy
some kind of playing his uniqueness was
not added to your own hmm he refused to
assimilate yes we thought it was futile
but uh yeah oh that was our mistake we
played the Comcast gambit Oh our
internet went out yeah
that's my move again
the French returns where's the link to
challenge you guys well there was one
wait wait at the start I should have
copy pasted it rain should I get it can
I see it again
can I get all the way up there I can
look at me go highlight oh gosh it's
okay I got it I got to actually open
this link in a new tab
ctrl C and then go away to the bottom
here and do some ctrl V Oh apparently
posted a million times
just a million times it's just 1 million
that should be good enough
go away Bishop no you can never get the
winning position out of the Comcast
gambit it is very difficult hello Caleb
Denby hello hello somebody earlier was
asking if you would be streaming for us
frequently Oh and nobody knows you are
off screen there's Caleb that's Kidder
yes there he is
hello I don't know evil be part of the
Borg
yeah we've been assimilating people
today and they don't they don't
understand the resistance is futile yeah
so are you gonna be streaming for us
more often would you like to be at least
I'd love to yeah cool yeah Caleb done we
definitely want the stream for us and
people's people have been asking for you
and wondering where you are
so you're here gonna be so popular in
flooded I'm here at this very moment
that's great Brooke Beulah Brooke you
might need some help yeah well yeah I've
got a little spicy here yeah but I have
to gamble all right
I believe in you and you believe in me
that's good I know I know
what he takes it I think I kept your
back okay that makes sense yeah it's
pretty good very good
cabbage it's for the week well sometimes
you have to dress in black did you hear
the Patrick Stewart is coming back to
Star Trek yes and I'm excited that's
cool
that is my ex I have exert his back so
excited hello my name is Joey he says
hello st. Louis people welcome there's
like tons of chairs you just grab the
chair and sit here if you wanted to come
crash come crash all right so my guy is
trying to invade come join us join us
yeah good luck with that
good I think you did a good job I'm
proud of you I do my best
you are the best you are the best oh
that that works kind of spicy for him
hey you're all of a sudden here like
winning how did his King get like in
front of all his pieces no strange yeah
now you have probably not good now you
have two bishops and we'll a number of
pawns for the rook the Goldbach then I
return to send them this is an amazing
the grandmasters can just do whatever
they want for 20 moves and then start
winning I just do that I'm gonna win
from some terrible position they decide
I don't know why I'm pointing out the
move that I'm going to make hmm who's
older Isaac or Jonathan Jonathan is four
years older than me yep oh my god oh my
god what are you doing wait a second
where did that go where did that go it's
gone what if that bishop go it's gone
it's a good thing there's a clock yeah
yeah
the clock is are in our favor it's gone
she gone she gone I don't know I don't
really have American accents do you have
American accents I've got a few American
accents what are your favorite
I like my I like my family's kind of
southern southern Midwest sorry about
this game I'm sorry next time I'll try
to meet you yeah you did not assimilate
him he resisted assimilation for as long
as possible he's a human my friend he
has four years older than me but is he
four times better at chess no he's he's
like 400 points better than me right a
little bit more than that probably
actually but I think depends on your
metric I feel I can't assimilate no more
so Caleb will take my hop in yeah Caleb
hop in it make sure to play navin
because he's been wanting to play yeah
he's got a lesson he's got to get to
well he just wanted a game yesterday you
wanted to play me yesterday and I didn't
give him a game do you have enough
chords on your body yet yeah Nevin let's
go yep
play that guy complete English Oh bye oh
by the way all rated game is llama Lord
yes play rated meanwhile I'm can like
confused because it's another trance
yeah I've been hiding for a while and
you guys knew Jonathan Schantz so well
behind the scene and I've been behind
the scenes for so long but now they they
kept me out of or that they kicked me
out of the box and said show your face
to the world and Here I am they said the
world needs you tell hello hello hello
world if Isaac then print hello world
hello world right that's this pretty
deep joke there pal I got there now you
understood it you took some computer
science class I did understand it I
don't think you have to take a computer
science class to understand that joke no
but you have to know anything about
computer coding that was the beginning
of computer coding I don't think the
solution is very good for me I'm getting
outplayed betty-ann you think you're I
think he has more space and development
and stuff yeah but his phone's isolated
so I'm winning there you go really
winning that was some solid analysis
there you sound very similar to John
yeah I do some very similar to him all
right both genetics and the fact that I
thought he was really funny while I was
growing up so I tried to copy him I've
analyzed all the squares I've decided I
should go back yeah just just go home
and cry if you ever needed to do some
deep analysis just hold the piece over
the square yep helps don't you know the
space is the final frontier yes it is
the final frontier I don't understand
that oh there is you watched my Star
Trek Isaac I watched a lot of Star Trek
with my dad when he watched it
which one the the next generation mostly
I feel like that was the best generation
yeah I got a little card is just real
cool I got into it like a year ago when
they put on Netflix but I haven't seen
too much just a couple seasons I in
college I went through a period of
watching the the original one with with
Kirk how old how's that I mean it's like
entertaining ish I got you
it's you know a show with stuff
happening I believe it okay I'm gonna
take this if he takes back can you take
a bomb well then my see two squares one
but maybe I can take it this way and
then and then not get totally pinned and
wrecked I don't think you're gonna get
totally wrecked I'm gonna do this I
don't think you're quite wrecked years I
was worried you might like have some
nonsense with like this but two moves
I'm just gonna play a three next and I'm
gonna move my knight never gonna be done
this move I think either of those moves
that you suggested but taking a taking a
piece is good the charisma is in the
blood of both fronts yeah thank you we
Jonathan learned how to be charismatic
and then I copied him it's all it takes
all it takes man just copy people
funnier than you and then you'll be
funny so I guess blame my sister if you
don't think I'm funny tarik McDowell any
advice for me Isaac
I played last game with Dennis need
advice to improve chess tactics tactics
tactics tactics don't do anything but
lots of times until you're a grandmaster
he scared me for a second he took my
knight and I was like wait whoa whoa
didn't I have that defendants like take
see - oh no I don't gosh let me try Nick
that would be terrifying if only Knights
could teleport
hair dye here guys that's how Donuts
became blonde yes obviously you actually
went to cosmetic school sure wow you
just get all the stuff yeah he's he's
got a counting problem yeah this is not
looking good for our buddy Navin here
you are up for teen material before you
take a piece you gotta count right you
know so I have two pieces defending and
he has two pieces attacking so that's
not enough for him to take you need to
have more pieces attacking in order to
come out ahead there that's true it's a
true story
yeah tarika all I can really suggest is
doing lots and lots and lots and lots of
tactics game Nevin and a good idea on
tactics is you set a time limit for how
long you're gonna look at that position
and you write down all of the lines in
every direction that you can see and
then and then you you go and you find
the answer and if one of your lines was
that answer and hopefully you chose that
line is the best one then good job you
did it but also if pronounced like Navin
yes Navin okay
Navin Simon I just heard I was excited
and I believed him yeah I said once and
I was a little wrong but yeah once you
uh if you find the rating or if you find
the correct answer to the tactics
problem and you picked that one as the
best line good job but then also go look
at the other lines if you get it wrong
look at the lines that you did calculate
out and go look at the evaluations of
them and say if you have a computer
engine that that can tell you the
evaluations of the different lines that
you tried you can tell which of your
calculation was good and which of your
calculation was bad and you'll learn
more
I'd like some faster time controls I
think there's three oh yeah this guy
likes really fast time controls so I
also want to try some material odds
games against some of the lower rated
opponents cuz that do you know how to do
that's a lot of fun
we know that you just played efore queen
h5 queen takes f7 and then BAM you know
your loves game okay cool I've done it
once before on here there's a lot of fun
it's pretty competitive we're gonna keep
going down from the top I want to play
all of you guys I wanna play you servic
I want to
I want to play you Victor well I don't
but but this guy doing after this I
think it'll help me
and mine you play the trump house key
Raptor attack I don't play the trump
house key I've never heard of the Trump
house key Raptor but that sounds a lot
more interesting than the Trump house
key maybe if if there's if Raptors are
involved you're more likely to play it I
might play it if they're if there's a
raptor on the chess board I'll play it
good alright I removed my challenge and
made a 301
my name is Joey as your name also my
name is Joey on Twitch what's up Mike is
yousef okay alright let's make sure to
play that guy's make sure play Yusuf
Islands what is Isaac's feat a rating it
doesn't exist um yeah I've never played
a video game alright I'm trying to put
my knight on this square looks like a
good place for a knight to be maybe
it'll help me win I don't know and then
if he takes with a bishop you take with
a jeep on open up a g5 I'll put some
some rooks on it that sounds like I
didn't think that far ahead but you know
sounds like you're pretty good at this I
did some of those calculating things no
not really
all right maybe a d5 for black hey just
break it all up
opponents playing on the wing playing
the center great
Oh on Leech su r ji for 12 Joe all right
we'll make sure to play that person it's
a great using in I met for four is that
too slow
probably yeah I slow for this guy this
guy doesn't have a long attention span
five plus over or faster is my
preference when Queen on the G Phi only
better probably yeah I'd uh I put some
queens on that G file there if I have
are you gonna make an effort I don't
think he can stop any of this from
happening King H it's the only move in
the Newark g8 ah can I cheer up g8 but
it's not so easy this is the Raptor
attack d4 Knight f6 Bishop g5 94 h4 oh
yeah
that's been played against me before oh
you missed queen g4 he had to play
finish eight last turns so you could
play grouchy eight on this turn but now
this just looks like mate good game big
a mess CP um do it for a ji something
numbers so follow buzz yeah ji for told
you all right all the way down here
I need 1700 on the king's Ahmed Queen I
don't check any Queens what are you what
is your leach s rating online blitz
ratings does 2300 is 3-3 2300 great it's
so good wait yeah I think you meant f5
pretty sure he meant have five or net of
six but it's not something like really
known you can't play that night you take
that yeah basically a checkmate them
alright I don't play E for so I have no
idea what the theory with the latvian is
so i'm just gonna play d3 this is the
Latvian gambit I'm just gonna play
normal chess yeah alright
b5 f5 it's it's big stuff if you don't
know what you're doing you're gonna get
you're gonna messed up so I'm just gonna
develop my pieces normally instead of
investing
really the the Raptor attack is ginger
GM favorite he likes to play crazy
positions I know he's a he's a fun chess
player to watch yeah there's some light
against the Trump house key where black
just goes like 94 g5 that looks like a
lot of fun I've never played it because
it's sad just going you know but you get
some fun stuff
you basically just attack White's Bishop
over and over again and say you're
winning time by doing it so I have this
nice d5 square he's a little bit
underdeveloped I'm not sure why this
rook is out here in in the middle of the
board because your Queens on that file
and he wants to attack it that could be
that could be the case he's attacking my
bishop I have to move my queen out of
the way actually some I'm pinned right
next game played the zero genius oh I
actually missed this smooth last turn I
think but I'll play it now it's double
check well that's a lot of check it's at
least two checks and one all right now
I'm trying to find some kind of
checkmate probably I should just start
with this this triple check possible no
no oh that was a mouse look cuz I guess
whatever whatever line you open up is
mr. Frantz junior at GM no none of the
Shawn Cesare a GM I don't believe
there's ever been a GM Schwantz both in
my family or not in my family
really maybe uh it's not an uncommon
last name as it is am I related to every
France ever I don't know how the names
work probably I unclear I guess
everybody is related to somebody if you
go back far enough I guess so
we're all family if you think about it
yeah that's a fork looks like a fork to
me that's a ste I think this game is
going well when I Mouse slipped Bishop
e6 I wasn't sure so sure but after I got
to take back I think I'm back in control
so this threatens checkmate but then a
so then he's gonna hit me with the
Bishop h3 I don't really want to get hit
with the bishop h3 so I'm gonna play
this instead
versus this queen to go somewhere it
doesn't want to go he's got to keep an
eye on this pawn mm-hmm right now I
think this move might just win look my
queen doesn't have a lot of places to go
and then you threaten a jerk man when
the queen is gone
well I'm threatening her right now oh
yeah so yep Queen g6 is forced now I
don't know I'm up a Brook so I'm just
gonna trade all the pieces yeah that
probably leads to any position okay now
I'm just gonna check me out him I think
because why I trade all the pieces when
you can checkmate them those are good
fine Ben as long as if you're like 20
300 or something let's see I gotta cut
off the f6 square he was trying to run
away you know did I move a king up next
turn um I could or I could check in the
knight g6 that's g-iii check over it
looks like he gets away so I'm just
gonna play on this this looks easier to
play the move you suggested I suggested
a move I'm the best I calculated three
moves ahead I had no idea what's
happening
so I played this one that's done please
keep playing people from the top and in
queue over 30 minutes yes I'm only doing
that for a few people who've been here
for days trying to get games other than
that we're gonna keep tag from the top
I could game you play from the top top
top top top top
oh it's casual all right please
challenge rate it from now on somebody's
got to save this accounts rating from
the likes of at the beginning I thought
Jonathan was a GM because the chess
opening explained are the best lectures
yeah many GM's have told Jonathan that
you're opening prep is like almost GM
level I mean Jonathan knows openings in
and out like nobody's business you could
chew oh yeah oh no pork you could chew
he's like miss might miss his chance
yeah do a ten seconds wait yeah I don't
know Jonathan could actually probably
get pretty high rated if he really tried
cuz his opening prep is insane and on
chess comm he got his tactics rating to
3,000 so I remember him telling Fabiano
Caruana my Tex rating on chess comm is
higher than yours and then a week later
that was no longer the case Fabiana what
did not stand for that it's a true story
he personally takes credit good game my
name is joey Fabiana do tactics yep
Johnna think she are you there
Wow nobody actually wants to yeah it's
all a big joke it's all the big joke
oh he came all right rated we prefer
rated Goku Khan see what I can dunk a
con man I'm gonna butcher that name the
more I try and pronounce that sorry I'm
gonna play I'm playing stuff I don't
normally play make it a little bit more
interesting
well spicy meatball yeah yeah I did I
did not do that you know it was plenty
interesting yesterday but that's because
you're way better than me play b6
I don't understand I'm I'm I'm confused
already
so what I'm gonna do here is I'm not
gonna develop this night for a while and
you'll see why in a minute
Isaac Kota do you have any any ideas why
I'm not gonna develop it um any thoughts
on that because you don't know if he's
gonna take on c5 ever or not not quite
it's a little more important than that
stuff is Bishop from ever coming to know
what's White's best piece in this
structure the dr. bishop
no the this was that one well you asked
me before that move happened it puts
pressure on this on this side of the
board and it's I don't know like all of
whites threats come from having this
bishop it supports the e4 break it's
works in tandem with Knight g5 are you
gonna put it on F so by delaying put
developing this night I have the option
to play this your basics here and try to
turn this off which is cool the way I
played it I don't think is actually
quite accurate because he delayed
playing Bishop d3 for so long but and I
just wanted to show the idea mm-hmm
what's Caleb's rating Lee chest it's
like 2,300 ish what's your what's your
USCF all right um I've been around 2160
2170 for a while all right so we got rid
of White's blessed peace for our worst
piece nice is you pretty big win
strategic win for you mm-hmm we didn't
even lose any time because he moved his
Queen twice to capture on d3 the only
winning move is to not play
hmm so he should occupy this square I
think try to get this through I'm
playing queen c8 because I'm gonna post
up on v7 where I can support the center
I'm gonna capture this he occupied that
square daddy did he must be listening or
maybe he just had the same idea
I shouldn't capture that I don't know
why he did it was kind of dumb what I'm
explaining to a noob why why it's so bad
it's not so bad but there was just no
need I think you know you know it's one
of those exchanges should either be
fantastic forced or I guess so a failure
I guess so oh so I tried to play the
latvian against a 2k plus player yep you
tried it didn't go out I don't think
that's the same I don't think the last
is the last word of that saying a
failure no but I believe I can't say it
was something else
I understand now though I actually
couldn't think of what the real saying
was and then don't make sense that's
what the phrase I've heard from Maurice
Ashley mmm Navin did you play a decently
for 800 player yeah you developed your
pieces and then you didn't hang them for
a while and then you tried to do stuff
that you didn't know you weren't quite
good enough to calculate and it's pretty
hard when you're starting out to know
when you can when you can take stuff but
usually counting helps and just doing a
few thousand tactics so at that level
the biggest problem people have is just
boardvision
so if you keep playing tactics and keep
playing games eventually you'll develop
boardvision and what that means is you
can look at the board and you can see
what squares are being attacked by what
pieces without thinking so hard about it
it's like I don't have to think okay
okay sure it controls all these players
I can just look at the board
and my brain kind of just realizes okay
all these squares are attacks I can't
put any pieces on there and now
sometimes this fails because you know
humans are fallible but that's what you
want to try to develop when you're
starting out is boardvision it's it's
some other f-word fantastic forced or
not good we're not good what NFL team do
you guys support I support the Minnesota
Vikings school
I don't support NFL teams I don't really
watch football as much as I used to but
if I had to read for a team it'd be the
Minnesota Vikings Isaac prefers tactical
or positional games very tactical lots
of my wins have actually come from just
making the position way too complicated
and freaking my opponent out and I look
there I sit there and I pretend that I
actually know what's going on and then
they flagged yeah just you know fake it
no bacon you fake it till you make it
Bluffs and chassis with some powerful
things whenever somebody play's a move
that I didn't expect sometimes I try and
just make the situation more complicated
and I don't try and resolve any of the
stuff that they want to resolve because
they understand that that resolves in
their favor okay I'm gonna try to get b5
through do minority minority attack here
who is the oldest GM playing in
tournament today in the top-ranking hmm
in the top-ranking it's got to be like
ananda kramnik oh it's got to be a non
right or whatever Kramnik cranek solder
yeah I know so yeah so I guess those two
are probably the best Topal I was
getting up there too but he's kind of
falling off from the top done good game
Abdel we ran out of time think he had
some connection issues yeah I like this
position for me though I'm just gonna
play b5 before make a weakness on c3 and
try to convert from there so he probably
is already but I missed it well rating
is Isaac I'm like 1350 USCF all right
component component component I'm gonna
try to do some Queen odds here I do some
Queen odds it's three plus three so it's
kind of ambitious to do you got this
with the three second increment life's
pretty tough for me football players
have inflicted too much misery on chess
players in American schools there's a
divide I hope that's not super true but
I'm afraid that it might actually be
somewhat true I'm hanging this pawn but
it'll open the C file so kind of a mixed
bag there I think maybe maybe I'm not so
upset about losing my seat
because there's not much I can do to
defend it now that I've given up a queen
put my queen on that square I mean you
could put a bishop in front of it I
could but trading pieces we're gonna
give you when you're given a queen it's
like awful yeah like you can you can
give up so much as long as you don't
have to trade the good news that secant
castle because of the way I gave up my
queen so I have compensation well then
is it true piece odds I don't know it's
tough to say so I'm trading a night here
I'm getting the strong bishop though and
this pins gonna be awkward unless he
does something like right now Isaac you
avoiding my challenge I'm not trying to
avoid any challenges we're just trying
to go down from the top yeah we're just
going to order the queues 15 people long
so it might take a second yeah we
chances are we don't get to all of those
challenges today because 15 games of
chess can take hours who was the best
known celebrity in the chess world who
was complete who's competed in a
tournament I guess not celebrity in the
chess world but just celebrity who's
competed in a big tournament I know what
he Harrelson's a big chess fan yeah I
think he's like 1500 or something he
played one of the first moves at the
world championship this year I remember
I'm not sure who else there was that
funny game between Bill Gates and Magnus
where Magnus just crush them watch them
all right I am losing yeah you don't
have a queen dude okay I'm gonna take
care
somebody says that GM Dennis Bohr else
is looking funny today yep he went to
the salon
yeah hair died you know aged backwards a
little bit
got a little bit younger a little bit
less beardy yeah lost the accent you
know gained a different one no God okay
so I broke your rule I tote I talked all
about not trading pieces and now I have
exactly one night left but but
compensation his kings on f3 could
there's no compensation in this position
he's only plus seven not plus nine
would you rather would you again he's
gonna play Queen takes Knight he might
he shouldn't but he might you should
have checked me and when I have to run
away it's gonna be a little awkward
maybe I should run to e7 that might be
the correct square things with this work
are getting a little hairy as well so
it's getting a little testy here yeah
this is gonna be difficult a little
testing this is not gonna be easy I am
threatening a three-way fork oh that's
the good news but it's a really any
better than a two-way fork no that's a
good fork it's not better than this
two-way fork that is it good work oh wow
suddenly we're up Monsieur you were
winning tragic tragedy strikes component
component
should be able to convert this I believe
in you you're also up a lot of time it's
not good enough that I could beat Magnus
in this position no improvement on but I
could beat a 2200 yeah
think you could beaten I am thinking
beat Eric Rosen in this position I think
I could I think I have the power
there's a chance that I lose it but no I
think I think I got I said I lose this
position more often than I should
everybody does I'm gonna capture here I
step out of this pin before he plays d5
okay
now I'm not actually pinned cuz he took
with the king so let's get the other
hook in the game piece activity is all
you need in unn games you've need your
pieces to not oh oh goodness I got
outplayed I got outplayed you got you
got rekt dude that's okay I can still
probably win this game you do have one
more pawn so was it just or you can try
and create a passer on the yep ye olde
king side that's is that the Queen side
that's the Queen side I'm gonna box the
zurka okay you might play rook c3
he chose not to and suddenly we are not
off a piece indeed
obviously something suddenly things got
much more even I have some devious plans
here though I have some devious plans
like this dudes a deviant watch out he's
gonna get you how many people are
watching us on different things
we got you've got 106 on YouTube and
twitch a steel chess club
and we have 85 on Twitch thank you all
for joining us we have nearly 200 people
watching us it's a pleasure to have you
here guys oops I missed I could beat
Eric Rosen in this position gets
skewered immediately by a 1000 I mean
let's be expected hello Aditya happy to
have you in the chat are you enjoying
the stream sir um me Danny any chance
you could bring me like any soda or
ginger ale or something just anything a
sprite
I could go for a sprite to you Danny
great 92 on Twitch now now yeah whoo
yeah I assume we'll get more viewers on
twitch once we actually have twitch
alerts set up we're working on figuring
out how to do that twitch alerts what do
you mean by that the the stuff where
it's like somebody subscribed and you
see that stuff or yeah there's all the
stream lab stuff yeah well Danny gave me
the most destroyed can obscure I've ever
seen Wow can you can we see how Dan for
this is look at that top there I have no
idea this is yeah I get the feeling it
should because my Rick is well-placed
I'm gonna go over here some attack this
spawn and also support my own yeah we
should make a highlight this is winning
now what if we can ever make stream
highlights such make highlight videos
because I know one highlight would be I
could beat Eric Rosen in this position
follow that you immediately getting
skewered hey but then I'm one so no
you're still a win but like Eric Rosen
probably would've beat me though problem
believe there's also there's highlights
and then those clips clips are what the
cool kid sees oh yes I guess whoa
they're just like 30 seconds long yeah
for that instant we're actually viewing
on Twitch yeah clips are best but like
for your YouTube content yeah like a
highlight video you know you condense
your seven hour stream into a ten minute
highlight video or something
alright you ready for the bishop night
mate oh he was not prepared for him
again good game component again
that was close i I was down the Queen
then I came back
than I lost anyways but then I won yeah
real rollercoaster
who was a rollercoaster of emotion okay
broseph brosephine it's quite the name
that was quite the name alright let's
see what I can do here
I'm gonna play some wandering King yeah
you can't play f sex and not boy king f7
well I needed my escape route first Oh
to go around yeah oh okay
I mean that's you can't just go into the
middle of the board with no with no
point no extraction plan you know
rematch against Isaac you lost against
him yesterday yeah I would love to play
you again
but today is not my day to play chess
today is the day for better tres players
to play because what people came here
expecting marginally better test it's a
pretty thick margin
those are like full 1 inch margins
they're all the way around the paper is
what inches that's not a big margin is
it four times paper oh I don't know I
just remember that's what mr. CUDA all
always made us do right so the benefit
of having my King on this side of the
board is that I can just push all these
puns mmm nobody's gonna stop me you can
push all your King side pawns and no
fear yeah like look this diagonal its
weak but my queens on it is this is this
the reverse delayed bomb Club still
theory says uh this this is something or
other I think Magnus played this and one
of the we chess titled arena's well he
did it but I thought he did it with his
Queen like he mood his Queen all the way
across and changed the K well he was
doing that as well but I think he did
this people this one out for one of them
nice do you know the bond cloud opening
yeah it's just it's just f3 king of two
that's all it takes
oh no wait maybe it's efore king e - I
think it's efore king e - yeah the king
and queen switched places
it was great I don't know I feel like
that that joke opening has outstayed its
welcome in my opinion I'd really just
cuz I name it got too popular it's
really just many people think it's fun
it's time for it to stop all right it
needs to put his foot down Nakamura stop
playing it didn't Nakamura I was one of
the popular eyes didn't he I believe I
just hear it on his stream all the time
there was also a big Lee chess
tournament a long time ago where if you
could win the most games while playing
that opening then you got some trophy so
everybody who's playing yeah that's
pretty funny like I know I know an IM
who has as the trophy on his account
it's pretty funny that's pretty great
let's see here oh my king seems weak
don't know how that happened I wonder if
it was all the wasted tempo wait that's
probably it it's probably him
all right my Knights attack so I'm gonna
move it you're a genius
yeah the eight free moves thing I don't
know that's uh that's a lot of moves man
the way this opponent played I think his
opponent just kind of fee and cut out
and stayed back which is not the way to
try to punish that you got to play like
you know d5 c5 d4 go get him I'm gonna
play Knight g6 to trade off this strong
night
I don't read about this f x square this
guy doesn't play the bond cloud anymore
because it's gotten too theoretical yeah
it's been overplayed as soon as there's
Theory two moves like that that uh I
don't know like the grodd is a timeless
classic but I don't think I don't think
II for King u2 deserves
when would you guys do viewers Choice
again um isn't that on Thursdays isn't
it today yes indeed I believe there's
gonna be one of those premiering tonight
either at 6:30 or 7:30 I don't know I
don't know which anymore joke opening
requests has anybody got any other funny
openings - I really do like messing
around like this it's a lot of fun for
me don't know if it's fun for you but
I'm enjoying it
haven't lost yet move all pawns one
square the wall of death here's here's a
big challenge for you I have not lost a
game on this livestream yet yes who's it
gonna be who's gonna breathe who's they
can the moon's gonna beat him
undefeated so far waste eight moves in
the opening who is it gonna be oh
there's a very difficult one that I try
and bullet tournaments sometimes where
you try to swap the Knights without
moving any other pieces Wow it's nearly
impossible because something takes up a
center square or something yeah and like
there's just no path river it took for
it to go but if you achieve it
what is your feed a up do you have a
feed a rating my feeling yeah it's about
2120 eat pretty pretty similar to your
yes UCF just a few less games played
probably it's about like 70 points less
I think mmm-hmm
which is pretty close to okay aid for
people okay cool can you say something
is is the fried liver and opening or a
trap to like people can fall into it's
an opening it's an actual opening which
has a trap in it which has a trap in it
okay I thought it what just wasn't the
fried liver until they fell into the
trap but okay I'm wrong it's the fried
liver attack okay maybe you can call the
night f7 the fried liver trap but I
don't think that's like an official name
I'm attacking this guy many many many
times you didn't take that bishop oh I
didn't see you know but I'm attacking
this guy so I'll then except for it yep
that makes up for it because he has to
the fun night no I can take this it all
works you saw it are only cool kids
allowed here at Caleb know you can be
uncool and enjoy the stream just the
same yes just the same the coolness is
more of a state of mind
good game broseph well thanks for
joining us broseph thanks a plan
Jonathan 2.0 is back when I'm doing all
this axe I am you should probably just
break it open right away like if you
want to if you want to actually track
meet me you just go right away here with
d5 I don't think there's any way I can
defend my king yeah and then your
bishops gonna come out to that floor as
well yes I've take stakes
Bishop f4 is just me we're almost Queen
Dix I think we takes actually mate yes
so I can't take so I would have to go
over right away yeah right
and then Bishop f4 is not quite made but
it's getting close then yeah I think you
have to block with a bomb yeah you're
you're gonna in trouble
all right the end he's played one blitz
game in his life I know in Caleb's dream
only cool kids are allowed I know
because Caleb kicked me out it's only
sometimes Wow who did I kick out znation
chess I didn't kick him out he claims he
did I just titled my stream cool only
cool kids allowed and then he was like
oh I guess I can't be here I'm sorry are
you older or younger than Jonathan they
are twins ooh
which of these is true those are three
options I am the younger of four or
young four youngest of two there's two
of us just me and Jonathan I'm four
years younger I just had a frightening
vision of for all of us yes please
bughouse against each other learning the
entire chess club by themselves yep it's
the Xiang family chess club Oh God maybe
the best chess club in the world
all right so we I don't know if you guys
saw the opening but the the best way to
count on the grab you just play h5 there
you go there you go hit him a pH five
now this is a structure I'm actually
familiar with but usually my bishops out
here cuz I played a Cairo
you scream on your own channel Caleb I
do on occasion yeah the only way to
actually get viewers is to do it very
consistently it's really hard
I get enough to have a good time with
all the matters yeah that's all you need
okay all right he's he's taken up quite
the dark square approach here so in
retaliation I think I want to break
break it open in the center with my king
uncle how many chests streams even are
their lives quite a few 1 2 3 4 5 6 now
a lot of those people have just set up
like some computer chess things and just
leave the stream running all the time
yeah and then some of those like there's
a couple people who just stream the top
game on like chess calm and they just
don't that they just have that up it's
kind of strange but so that number is
only 9 just streams 29 and like half of
them appear to be just computers playing
chess yeah it's kind of annoying because
there's only actually not that much
competition I mean I guess we're
competing with pro league and uh you
know former US Champion yeah Nakamura is
a pretty popular guy I uh
okay I think I'm winning no I've managed
to play b6 and take on c5 so it's the
center's kind of collapsing I have
problems of my own but I think I should
be able to handle them you're a big boy
you know
well well well you know are you gonna
play Knight c5 and try and trade those
Knights
no tradings for losers I'm gonna get
castled I was thinking you could I mean
I was thinking just lots of trade stuff
but I want to go Knight e5 and that is a
better place for your knight to be you
got attacked
I did get attacked but yeah that's
really I moved away you're so good at
moving away and not losing pieces
hey that defense this gives up the c5
square but then b2 is hanging
interesante
I like it I like it a lot
I don't think vens gonna be the first
one to beat me nope I don't think it's
gonna happen
it might even you it might not even
happen today it might not happen ever I
don't think you've lost a game in chess
in your life do you know what losing
feels like I can't recall what was that
word even mean losing alright I believe
it's a made-up term I would agree okay
so he's defending the d3 square I'm
struggling to find some way to finish
this game off somehow he's putting up
quite the resistance he's he's putting
up a fight I think you're going down man
I need this see five squares what I need
so I'm gonna play rook c8 attempting to
threaten to play c5 also hanging my rook
again nice I'm really missing these
tactics - you've got a skewered a few
times today thing is I'm losing I'm not
so worried about this one
you're gonna lose dude I'm not so
worried about this one though where is
that b6 cuz I have this move mm that
could suck I don't want to take this
trick though I just want my knight on d3
okay oh he's tempting me to just like
take care but it's bad I can't do it I'd
love to but I can't think of too glad
I'm gonna have to pass right now he's
like still want you to do it dude he
really does whoa I'm gonna take care of
first they're going to take that with
check whoa okay now I'm gonna take here
threatening mate woo you can check me on
ei maybe I'm worried about it yeah I'm
not worried about it you're so brave
wait this isn't mate his knight comes
back but I can take his knight
it's okay you are the bravest little
fish that ever could
it takes a brave man to do this when
your opponent has an hour on the clock
yeah it doesn't take a brave man to do
it when your opponent's five seconds
yeah I guess that's true
all right yeah I think I'd rather be you
at this point time to call it quits I've
got three pieces for the rook I think
this is a favorable and balanced it's
quite the imbalance good game Jen that
was interesting that was a valiant
effort with the grub
I always appreciate all right red clap
960 rated you should play some chess 960
yeah play some chess 916 that means you
have to get all of your pieces back on
the rank on the first rank where they
didn't start there's one line in the
nihms oh that I play it where you
actually accomplished that
almost I think the knight and the bishop
in the rooks stay in the same place but
I think everything else you're gonna
have to innovate man I'll see what I can
do innovation will count what count
castling is like that King is not and
that rook is not where it used to be
yeah so you're like almost done with the
King side I'm just gonna do the Queen
side yeah there's that all right Hank
side done how to rearrange Queen side
though you're gonna do like a similar
thing I think I'm gonna do something
like that but then I can't I can't move
that Bishop it's awkward I'm gonna have
to trade places with a king or the Queen
and the yeah you do 97 to be six to
eight and then slide the rook over one
fish up up Queen over I have to put the
bishop on a eight because there's no
other square there's no other square for
a bishop
oh no how are you gonna get wait a
second it's not gonna be a legal 960
position because my king is on the wrong
side of my right it's not to be a legal
960 position but like I'm gonna give you
I'm gonna give you props for effort
though yeah I appreciate that
let me give you effort props so the
Queen and your queen needs to be on that
other dark square then the plan yeah
what we'll get there okay we'll get
there we're good to her plus Bishop d7
Knight c 8b 6
up and over and then uh he has something
like that
meanwhile checkmated while this is all
going on we're putting in the effort
it's okay I think we're safe and I think
I think white is for choice but I think
we got this hopefully doesn't try to
trade pieces with us so it's gonna ruin
all our plans yeah if you trades pieces
we can't put them all back on the first
plank because we don't have it before
okay here's a good move here anybody has
more than 100 there is one good one oh
no all right we have to avoid the trade
for traits no nobody can take it because
two things attacking that no you have
two things davinia yeah can't take it
see that's the thing when you move all
your pieces around like this your
opponent's gonna get a little confused
yeah what is this position I've never
been here barely confident he's never
seen this or I don't think quite like
this I'm sure this is a novelty goodbye
a guy in box I hope I didn't miss you
saying goodbye I hope this was recent
enough pleasure meeting you too my name
is Joey okay thanks for the game Caleb
this was the move that was worrying me
instead of some day I'm gonna have to
defend my f7 square against against my
my wishes I do it to defend f7 it's too
much to give up it is too much I think
we failed we didn't do it no no we're
gonna try again next time it was close
we got pretty close we the Queen was out
of place
I wonder if you need to do both sides of
the same time as opposed like just all
the kings I am The Queen side I wonder
if it takes the same you my new moves no
matter what you do but like we were
running into problems where the
LightSquared bishop only had one square
to go to like maybe the bishops need to
change sides maybe that's the most
efficient well alright we'll see we'll
see innovations will be made I'm not so
sure this one is the most interesting I
mean I think we have better ones there's
what I like to do that I do this in
bullet all the time so you try to make a
path for your king you leave your King
on e8 and then you try to make it so you
can run to the h-file and then to the a
file without moving any other piece it's
a lot of fun go around the world do it
okay it's opening up this diagonal but
this vampire chicken says does this guy
even know how to play chess big-time new
playing here big-time no big-time do all
right
I have LightSquared problems you do you
should play Knight g5 I was kind of
surprised you didn't trade that night
for the bishop well I didn't have a
chance I was in check like but weren't
you in check by the bishop yeah but then
he just takes with the Queen right then
the Bishop's gone okay I just thought we
wouldn't want that Bishop you're not
checkmating us personally everyone have
to give up this Rick I think are we can
mmm stuff it's tough man surely there's
there's some better way and don't call
me Shirley all right there's no better
way that's it you're done for me to do
this you got to do what you got to do
all right this is quite the imbalance
somehow you're up an amount of stuff so
you have two pieces and two pawns for
the rook I do believe I'm winning yeah
I'd still rather be you somehow somehow
someway still rather be you so he's
threatening like Queen f3 stuff how do
you guys call poor chess players here we
say Cappy vatos I think the coolest is
Rufus and doofus that's not a real
that's not a real term we don't think we
have a word for best chess player that's
a bad chess player uh whose words most
started with beat people call people
fish fish you know oh there's like limp
fish there's like fall over kinda it's
an older term I think like I think bobby
fischer called some people fishes what
did that have something to do with his
name is this like a name punt anger no
it was just like that's just what you
well he also just called people the
wikis oh that's something you don't you
I don't think that one caught on the
think that was just a bobby thing Oh Pat
sir yeah Pat sir is another good name
for a bad chess player there you go
that's a good word
don't know how I didn't think of that
yeah me neither Patsy's check Pat's
replace check night of five coming
defending attacking hey we said those
things as pets are mostly a poker term
maybe though fish comes no no fish comes
from the world of gambling at cards yeah
yeah I believe that it's probably cuz
it's like you can like hook a fish and
you can catch a fish and you make lots
of money in progress off of said fish
yeah I've heard I've heard the term
getting hooked in chess before as well
mm-hmm leave play versus GM Craig or
there's also an actual term where you
can have a hook in chess yeah this is an
unfortunate pin this comes up a lot in
positions where the bishops on this
diagonal game read clop that was a you
put you put me that's quite a bit of
pressure yeah you actually yeah I was
kind of close star from the top stir
from attack yeah I know you're just
reading the difference I'm just reading
their names a happy pawn I remember
playing you yesterday or Perry playing
it yesterday mmm okay all right let us
try the grab when someone comes into the
card game or casino and everyone knows
them and they always lose they are a
fish you got whales the high money
rollers and the fish the ones that just
can't win to save their life so many
analogies Karpov equals fish in Russian
I don't know if that's true probably
doesn't maybe it maybe it is true I'm
gonna go here put some uncomfortable
pressure on the spawn I'm uncomfortable
I don't know what he's gonna do about it
yeah that gives up this one
anyway taffy had defended with the other
night you push your bond ranks oh maybe
ninety-seven was forced but then his
pieces are awkward he can't develop this
Bishop mm-hmm
this one is a bit worse though a happy
pawn is a streamer it's not true can I
find you
maybe he might not be streaming right
now why not be streaming right now he
might be a streamer that's true maybe he
doesn't actually stream chests maybe you
stream something else it's also about
also possible we got to stop saying the
same things at the same time we are just
too much alike it's kind of freaking me
out yeah this art which title is now
allied GOM Dennis Boros is no longer
playing the people I'm you know I'm
channeling him I feel like I'm feeling
your inner alright good I feel like I'm
Dennis at heart
you're up a lot of stuff I'm up at night
I'm up a couple ponds I'm up time I'm up
on life and I believe you have all of
the advantages he is beating me in
development but I'm still beating him in
King's safety so it's not like his
leading development is well I guess his
rooks are better than yours it's gonna
take me a couple moves to develop this
Bishop as well mm-hmm but it's fine it's
fine everything's fine this is a problem
for him
no dude who's gonna fork your Bishop at
night you need to put that well I was
gonna take his Bishop but now I'm
thinking I might just try to checkmate
him instead
yo yep I can get behind this yeah this
move is silly and shouldn't be played
well knows my kindig-it yeah but then I
play Bishop before mmm and then I'm
going for him you know you're really
piling on the pressure I will just take
this bishop though it's it's the
responsible thing to do you're so
responsible we're so proud of you now
I'm gonna play d4 though Oh carp is a
type of fish carp true true
so Karpov was a fish Oh Karpov it is is
carp which is a fish oh that's funny
how about that it doesn't mean fish oh
that's funny yes yep all right we have a
20 minute countdown until C minutes
remain all right I got in this game fast
then well let's find checkmate you and
me together
we can do it
mmm-hmm don't lose the night for free
good job I'm so proud of you all right
this next game I'm gonna try to never
dip below three minutes that's online
that's my plan
but what if it's a three minute game
that's just ya know
Thank You Nicholas gonna be difficult
hello Ryan Chester yeah party never
stops never ends
alright this is the stream that never
ends I'm really struggling to find
checkmate here yeah David Dennis Poros
left he was here for about an hour and a
half and then he had to go to lessons
and go teach people chess this is the
plan other than us twenty thousand
twenty minutes checkmate
not yet it's a big it's a big question
who's gonna be the first one to beat me
yeah I haven't lost in my entire career
on this chess stream good game a happy
pawn you hung something terrible a while
ago servic I don't think vampire chicken
was talking to you I think he was
talking about this guy being the noob so
you usually want this structure against
the grab so you can defend against this
long diagonal putting the knight on c6
makes things a bit more weak over here
that'd be my advice to you
I have news I just play h5 or something
well yeah that was a joke though no oh
it's hard to tell sometimes this is the
first time I've seen my rating over 1900
stop playing so well Congrats
it was a group effort st. Louis put
chess where it should rightfully be here
in America I've heard they have a
wonderful Museum there yes we do right
across the street there's a really nice
Museum and the World Chess Hall of Fame
they have three different floors all
with three different exhibits the top
floor is the hall of the actual Hall of
Fame and they have on the first floor
it's kind of artsy chess stuff and then
the second floor is like historical
chess sets and chess pieces and bunch of
yeah it's fine I draw arrows too and
sometimes I just tell them what I'm
threatening I'm trying to use less than
15 seconds this game do you think I can
do it Isaac I believe in you it's gonna
be tough it's gonna be pretty hard I
don't trust him to not play Bishop e5
here so I'm not moving mm-hmm he figures
it out he might yeah
you might realize you've removing
everything we already want a piece two
seconds and we bought a piece wow that's
a pretty efficient one-piece for every
two seconds
now I'm gonna guard my g5 square we need
to keep those odds up though you need to
win a piece by the time you're at 456
expect you have won another piece will
do will do all right now he's pinned
that's good that's good
I'll get on the file you're gonna move a
knight
d7 c5 well you're ahead of me you're
ahead of me oh you went oh you went that
way yeah and c5 you can take it okay
fair enough fair enough
I didn't like that you make salient
points I've only got one second to win
another piece by your metrics yeah if
you're up a piece at 456 oh I figured it
out you're making negative progress he
figured out what you were up to what you
didn't take it
what very strange okay I'm confused my
friend went there a few years ago and he
said it was a great experience that that
is the chess Mecca for anyone who comes
to the region yeah thank you very much
Ronin returns yeah weird we're very
happy to have people come here to the
museum and check it out check out the
Hall of Fame and come play some play
some games at the same tables that some
of the world's greatest play that's
great
good night servic all right Ryan what
are the planets up to tonight he left
already gone he's already gone we're at
3 seconds and I think I'm approaching
checkmate
that you're getting pretty close
uh yeah I'd rather not gonna pre move
anymore cuz I'm concerned that he's
gonna hang something I think you're
pretty safe with the 15 second thing
yeah I should have set more ambitious
goals that's a bet oh well that was a
man if he had blowed no all right oh oh
oh my I expected in the block with rook
f3 because King h4 doesn't make too much
sense oh my it's okay though
we're not in any danger what Mike and
your oh Jesus I can be checked yeah
Oh vine P our chicken ass what are the
planets up to do this okay vampire
chicken there is a lunar eclipse can i
mom it on Sunday that will affect a
bunch of people it depends on what time
you were going with it thanks your birth
chart or not so you'll be safe
your brother will not we don't know
what's gonna happen just don't get into
a car with him alright this game has got
interesting yeah he realized you were
pre moving and started taking advantage
of such things oh I thought he would go
for the jaw alright
we're happy you didn't go for the jaw
we're concerned he's gonna go for it now
though yeah you're there's no way you
win this at 4 seconds now no way I beg
to differ
alright go for it you've as far as
planets are up to you there is a super
Blood Moon coming up on January 20 21st
the Wolf Moon zero degrees leo
no because you can actually do
directions by those signs oh my you are
his brother yes I am I am vampire
chicken's brother
we're in some danger here
I crossed 15 seconds you lost dude I
think he ought to resign
Wow yeah you lose dude that's ok you
thought you could do it I thought I had
you thought you had it I'm not giving up
hope yet that's what you good for being
cocky sir he played some moves that I
just could not see coming he realized
what you were doing
he got me he got me again you were that
in fact not immortal you can be taken
down all right to make up for it I'll
win this one in five seconds whoa
kick Caleb out bring Runyon in nice
Danny how much time do we have like one
more game after this one okay maybe one
or two more games depending on how
generous caleb is feeling it happen
sometime indeed
somebody yet lose some time I disagree
that's loser talk if you have infinite
monkeys making infinite chess moves
against you eventually you lose nope
put an infinite number of games disagree
thirteen hundreds are tough man oh I
forgot I was doing this I agree I forgot
what I was doing I already failed
you know you've like already lost him
for 15 seconds since then yeah he tried
that last time didn't go well I kind of
just zoned out started playing moves you
thought you had already won and you
infected not know the game had not yet
reached its conclusion
alright subtle threat here it's a little
threat oh well Queen outside was the
threat he's navigated that move
I'm fine giving up this bishop I only
have two seconds I forgot I was doing
this thing again all right we're gonna
go fast
Osumi her to do I believe in you
you got this you're totally not gonna
lose again because you're trying to do
something silly
I would never I've never seen it happen
Oh fine it's fine I planned this I knew
this would be okay
you knew that this was fine please take
my queen he's gonna take he's got he's
got to take my queen right now he's you
knew what the viewers no deed there
watching you didn't take my queen no
taking Queens for the week he might
actually have looked at your pre move
and nah our viewers have too much pride
for that you think so too honorable I
didn't think I'd rather win I think that
is out here raiding hunting that's okay
this is gonna do wonders for his splits
rating yeah I'm not giving away any more
points to Jeff not if you just I always
told you I'm sorry
the only prisoners allowed to do that is
my mother hmm are you my mommy mm not
quite
not quite tuned in late can anyone
challenge over at leech s what are our
time controls yeah you can challenge
this ugly chest but unfortunately we're
only playing a couple of more games we
got maybe 15 more minutes left ten more
minutes left
yes problem we'll get to you today
rubble won't get to you today we
probably actually only have time for one
more game after this one you don't need
to play the fast he moves like that will
mess you up yep that is a bit of the
point though he's trying to see if he
could making it a bit harder on myself
he was trying to have 15 seconds on his
clock play for real please I was
enjoying the good chess oh this isn't
good chess all right last game of the
day will be good chess yeah I promise
that's a spicy meatball there it's a
pretty good one all right
still once it was a valiant effort you
deserve that now you know just play
whoever's on top all right sir Knicks
last game of the day now punishes our
Knicks let's go the best chess in my
life right here yeah well well hopefully
see you next time ronan returns mic
starts streaming tomorrow at 2:30 the
earlier you get in the more likely you
are to get your game played the earlier
you challenge the more likely we are to
actually be able to accept it isaac is
cocky I guess if you're really smart
you'll show up at like when does my
start 2:30 you'll show up at 2:00 and
send a challenge and just let it sit
yeah maybe yeah you'll be the first one
then you're in there
I'm not sure why this person thinks I'm
cocky I've said nothing but I'm like
really bad at chess all day long all
right this this games going quite well
I'd rather be you oh that's true oh it's
true I'm Isaac yeah this is Caleb hello
the one playing is the friend I have
been a bit cocky today oh you changed
that thing I should we should make one
of those with Isaac on the left or the
right kind of left depending on which
way you're talking about mm-hmm
Caleb is cocky ah you're too cocky Caleb
I don't think I can deny that statement
I am more than a thousand points higher
rated than most of these people though
so that's where the cockiness is coming
from
cool look forward to seeing you then
ronin returns very cocky and you are
what you eat okay you're just I read in
that read it out on it okay all right
I'm gonna sacrifice this bishop because
I like losing pieces just kidding I
thought I would I thought it would get
him like bishop basics Queen takes rook
here and then his problems but I don't
think it's enough ma'am he doesn't have
enough problems
not enough problems I've noticed a
threat don't get rekt don't get forked
you were trying really hard to say don't
get forward today or not to say just got
back and wow Dennis got a lot younger
yes he does yes he did yes he did yes he
does has he done indeed he done did it
all right I've got to have something
here pretty soon you like God yeah it's
got to happen somewhat soon it's the
crime against chess if I don't find the
win here this ought to be the trick
bishops pinned I just hung a rook okay
you did all right
no I didn't yeah I did did I I don't
know I'm bettin you did that's okay I
would trade Queens that's okay that's
okay
we'll get we'll get it back we will get
it back
it's a crime against chess if I don't
find a winning rook see one there you go
you found it you certainly did check
this is this is what it was all about
yeah I think that check made things
worse for you nah just didn't help I
think you're going down I disagree I
think you're done for I disagree yeah
they said that yeah but they were not
talking about me they meant me the I
meant Caleb yeah
what for sure okay well done tomorrow
he's the one trying to win in five
seconds or less not me
he found a win for the opponent it's
true he hungry John Caleb did find a win
for his opponent I remember at the start
of this game Caleb said I'm gonna take
this one super seriously and crush them
I did I took it very seriously dude he's
only like two he's doing great
Dennis says Dennis knows who's gonna win
this game he's seen it happen before
where's this night gonna go you call
that a piece but what kind of a piece is
it really I mean if you can get a temple
on your rook last turn but he didn't you
went after a pawn with the king I'm just
gonna trap this Knight is that easy yeah
I did you did that there it goes nice
dead yeah but really the Queen I thought
he could have done that last turn no he
had not f1 to e3
yeah he did and then it was gone all
right the crushing has commenced
this is how I went all my blood skins
who is that in the background chez Dede
yep
shady Dennis shady Danny shady Dennis
yeah we got we got shady Danny and shady
Dennis thank you Thank You Nicholas nice
game see you next time yeah thanks a lot
thank you for the compliment Dennis says
the you suck Dennis said it Dennis
Senate I confirmed it on streem dude
that was the last game of this stream
alright
yeah this one is so ugly yep it was a
beautiful way it doesn't have to be
pretty it counts it still counts as a
win all winds are pretty wins
Oh winds are pretty winds all right I
thank you guys for joining us this was a
pleasure to play you guys today I played
some Hannah brain with Dennis slaw and
Caleb came in and finished the stream
out again we're looking forward to
eventually being able to get the the
twitch alerts to show up on the stream
so you've got to actually message us on
the stream and and your your donations
and sub lurtz will actually pop up and
we're working on that and then tomorrow
at 2:30 my camera will be here so join
us tomorrow for might come replace the
people all right
I'm Isaac Tron guys next time this is
Ben Caleb Dendy goodbye